A show where four women
get together to talk,
mostly about
their mutual friend Janelle.
Let's gab.
(applause)
Hi, hi!
Oh, they're cute, thank you.
So did everybody have an
exciting weekend?
Oh, you know what?
I want to start,
because Saturday
I had a day.
What happened?
Well, you know, I was picking up
my new rescue puppy Simon.
(audience)
Aww...
Stop.
You have to rescue.
There's no other way.
On the way home,
ran into guess who?
(imitating fanfare)
Don't tell me.
Janelle.
Oh, I knew it.
Janelle, okay?
Of course.
So we're saying goodbye, and she
kisses me on both cheeks.
Oh, my God.
Like, um, I'm sorry,
are you the duchess
of Brussels all of a sudden?
Yeah, it's like, uh, USA?
Well, Amy's already
got us started,
so I think we should
just get right into it.
Our "Big Issues" segment.
Oh, people love this,
love it.
Okay, I have a huge issue with
Janelle's Facebook page.
Ugh. Who doesn't?
Don't we all?
Hashtag "hope this day
never ends"?
Um, that's what days do,
Janelle, they end!
And B, uh, we know
his name's Steve.
Like, you know she just
wants to say "fiancé."
So French.
I can't.
There's something, like, off
about this dude.
Mm-hmm, something is up,
something's up.
I actually really
like him.
Yeah, but, like...
come on.
Oh, yeah, totally.
He is weird.
Right!
So weird.
Well, we're onto our segment
where
we check Janelle's
Instagram.
Oh, my God,
this is the best.
Wow, shocker.
It's about her cat again.
Like, we get it-- its fur
makes it look like
it's wearing a tuxedo--
who cares?
Oh, God.
Do you know that that cat,
I heard, isn't even a rescue?
Shut up.
She bought it, yeah.
No.
I knew it.
You know where she got it?
The mall.
She got a mall cat.
Oh, my God.
That is so disgusting.
Oh, my God, you guys.
I just got a DM from Janelle.
Oh, my God.
Should we read it?
Uh, it says, "Heard about
the new show, ladies.
I'm sure it's great
'cause you guys are the best."
She knows I'm at work.
Like, I'm at work.
Yeah, it's like, we're working.
We're working.
All right, you guys, stay with
us, 'cause when we come back,
we'll be interviewing Janelle's
personal trainer,
who she met with once.
(laughing)
At least she went.
Okay, do you want to be
a part of this show?
(applause)